Imagine this. You grow up as the
daughter of a powerful witch doctor. One
who speaks directly to Satan.
>> A lot of people who did oultu, they
would say, "Okay, you have to go buy
this animal and bring it back and we'll
do such and such and such." He didn't do
any of that cuz he worked directly with
with demons face to face.
>> And you you see the devil with your own
eyes, right? So, he pretends to be your
friend. He draws you deeper into the
world of dark magic. They need to do a
sacrifice for me. They drain the blood
of the lamb into a like a bowl and then
they drenched me in it from head to toe.
>> You learn how the music industry,
Hollywood, and even who wins the Super
Bowl are all influenced by those who
make sacrifices to Lucifer.
>> So, you would know like who's going to
win beforehand because it's going to be
um the demons that control the game. You
would come to him and he would say okay
and then you know you would win every
game you win
>> like the Super Bowl right like you
mentioned.
>> Yeah.
>> But then Jesus steps in. He breaks the
chains, opens your eyes and shows you
that Satan's power is nothing compared
to Christ's. This is Lauren's story.
Once trapped in darkness, now set free
by Jesus. And what she lived through
will shock you. But what Jesus did for
her, that's the real miracle. Today's
episode has been recorded at the studio
of Heritage and Hope Ministries, our
good friends of the show. Enjoy LED
Live. So, I'm originally from Trinidad
and Tobago in the Caribbean.
And I grew up um
my dad died when I was two.
>> Okay.
>> So, I grew up primarily with my mother.
But um
so I grew up kind of on the other side
of the fence if you can say it that way.
>> Okay.
>> Um we didn't go to I went to a Roman
Catholic school.
But other than going to church with the
school, I didn't really attend church.
>> Yeah. So, it was just my mother and I
and um
my my dad before he died, my my dad was
into
I I would say voodoo.
>> I want to say witchcraft, but I feel
like voodoo is a little um
stronger.
>> Yeah.
>> So, so is this common down there in the
Caribbean?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
But out of um I would say he was kind of
like high up like he was
higher than most of the other people
that practiced it.
>> Okay.
>> So yeah, so he would have politicians
and sports people and people that were
not even from that country would come
over there to to see him. Hm.
>> When you say high up, is that like like
what was his official title or position?
>> He would probably just have been known
as a witch doctor.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Okay.
>> Like a Yeah, like a voodoo priest.
>> Kind of. Yeah.
>> What are the uh Are you able to
elaborate a little bit on the
differences between witchcraft and
voodoo?
>> So, I think with witchcraft, people can
be like a lot of people call themselves
a white witch.
>> Gotcha. and in their minds they're not
killing anyone or that you know they're
not murdering
people and um but like voodoo it's like
you it's it's like really deep oult
>> right okay
>> so like yeah you'll you'll be sitting
there talking face to face with Satan
kind of thing
>> whoa
>> and yeah and
>> so there's no disguise
>> yeah so like one time my dad and the
neighbor never had an argument because
the neighbor said my dad's fence was 2
in too much on his
on his property. And I don't know why he
would even make that an issue because
everybody knew who my dad was.
>> And so they had this argument and then
three days later the guy was dead. He
just didn't wake up. Wow.
>> And that was because
he said something about the fence.
Wow.
>> Yeah. So that I grew up and my dad had
um
I have four brothers and sisters that I
don't know. I've never met them,
>> but they were already grown up because
my dad was like 60 and I was born and my
mom was in her 20s and she was not there
because she wanted to be.
She was also there because he kind of
used his powers to to get her and then
keep her there. So she wasn't there
willingly.
>> Mhm.
>> And so um when he died
before he died he expressed that he
wanted me to carry on
what he was doing. And I don't know why
he chose me because like I said I had
brothers and sisters who were willing.
>> Mhm. and I was little, but he chose me.
And um so when he died, my mother kind
of just carried on,
I guess, trying to groom me. So she she
found um other people like him
to keep me around so I can kind of
get into it.
>> So there wasn't much of a choice for
you?
>> No. No.
And that, you know, when I was older,
like about 16, I used to feel like, why
don't I have a dad? Like, everyone else
has a dad and I don't have a dad. And I
used to feel so sad. But when I got to
know the Lord, I knew that it was in my
best interest
>> that I did not grow up with him. Because
if he had that much power
and he
would have trained me firsthand,
it might have gone a different way for
me
>> if he lived.
So, I kind of think that was better that
he didn't. And um
when I was about 7
6 or 7
um I I used to I started getting ill
every month of April
and
my mom nobody knew what was wrong with
me. The doctors didn't know what was
wrong with me. I would just lay there
and be like in a in a coma like thing
and if she didn't wake me up and and
feed me
>> I would just never wake up. So every
April she would have to take me out of
school and eventually you know the
someone like my father told her
um
they need to do a sacrifice for me. M
>> so they took me to the countryside and
um we got there sometime in the day. I
was little so I don't remember much. Um
it was in the daytime and there was a
lamb like a a a a baby sheep
and they said this lamb is for you. And
I thought oh how nice I have a pet. So I
was just playing with this lamb all day
but then when it was night time like
midnight
they killed it
>> in front of you? Yeah.
>> And then so I was dressed in like a
white dress
and then
they drained the blood of the lamb into
a like a bowl like a wooden bowl and
then they drenched me in it from head to
toe and I remember feeling the um you
know blood it it coagulates
>> and I remember my skin feeling tight. I
remember that much. And then they made a
circle and it was outside so it was
pitch dark
and they had candles all around and and
I was in the middle of the circle and
then um
so there was drums and there were
chanting and and then someone picked me
up and threw me to someone at the far
end of the circle. It was a big circle.
So, I'm thinking, please don't let
anyone drop me, but that's all I'm
thinking. I'm comfortable with it
because
I'm used to that kind of stuff.
And and then someone threw me back. You
know, they were kind of making a shape
of some sort.
>> And then when that was over, I never got
sick again. But, you know, that's just
how the devil works. He makes you sick
in the first place.
>> Yeah. And then you come to him for
healing and you think, you know, he
heals me.
>> But really, I wasn't like that was a
whole ritual. I wasn't healed. I was
more possessed than anything after that
point.
>> I've got just a couple of observations
here. Um, you know, it's interesting
when you mentioned that they were
lighting candles in a circle. I know
there the circles often and the candles
like that often to do with the occult,
but also a lot of Christians believe in
lighting a candle, you know, like in the
church, lighting a candle for a dead
loved one. You light a candle in front
of that picture, but this is rooted in
the cold is what I understand of it. And
like you see that they're doing it with
you too.
>> But also, I found an interesting
observation. They were using a lamb. You
were dressed in white and you got
covered in blood. That's very
Christianlike.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Why do you think they did that
specifically? Why is such a copy of
Christianity?
>> I think Satan copies a lot of stuff that
um
that that Jesus has. And also some of
the things like as I g as I grew older
and I would participate in different uh
events and rituals and things like that,
one thing I remember there was always an
open Bible.
>> H interesting. But we we never read from
it.
>> So what I think that was
>> was to give the illusion that all of
this had to do with God.
>> Yeah.
>> Because one thing my mother always told
me and know when I would question her
about what we're doing, she would say
this is from God. Like God put some
people on this earth to do these things
to help other people.
because I always questioned,
you know, like why are we doing these
things? And that's what she would say.
But in my head, if someone came to us
and said, I need this person dead,
how was that us helping somebody? How
was that God telling us to help someone?
Mhm.
>> But um that was I think it was just to
copy because even Satan himself when he
would come to us in our meetings he
would say it was most times it was
always Saturday.
>> Really?
>> Yes. And he would say this was his day.
>> Huh.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. So, would you ever uh see any of
the the demons or spirits or anything
like that or
>> I did I used to
>> really
>> I used to be able to and it was never um
they it would be in the form of um of
people it they wouldn't take their
original form to me.
>> Okay. So they would always look like
folks, but I knew that they were nobody
else could see them. And yeah.
>> Did they look any different than a
standard person or No,
>> I can't tell you facial features.
>> Mhm.
>> Because for some reason that was always
kind of cloudy.
So, I could see everything else, but I I
couldn't give you specifics on
big eyes, small eyes, like I I I
couldn't tell you.
>> Did seeing them start after the ritual
you described or was it even before
then?
>> Yeah, I saw them after that. And after
that, I had to wear like a little pouch.
>> Um, they would call it a guard cuz it
was supposed to like guard you from
evil.
But now that I know I I I was the evil.
So I don't know.
>> It was not guarding me from anything. It
was just giving them a doorway.
>> Right. Right. It's an illusion of power.
>> Yeah.
>> Are there So even in voodoo, is it fair
to say that maybe at the lower levels
there there are kind of people who feel
like maybe they're using dark for good,
but then once you get higher up, you
know that it it's Lucifer, Satan
himself.
>> Yes. Yes. because there were um people
that would come that would show up to
our meetings and our
events. Some people were in church, some
people were Muslim,
>> you know, show up in the full Muslim um
stuff, but they all but they felt like
this was okay, like this was from God
really. And so that's why I think we had
the Bible and
never occurred to anybody. We've never
opened it. We've never read it like it's
just there.
>> Kind of reminds me what they do in a
Freemason lodge
>> when they have the Bible open and kind
of the whole ecumenical everybody kind
of come in. This is also kind of
reminding me of Roger Morno's testimony
because Roger Mornau said that the the
demon worship that would occur um they
would take Christian hymns
>> and they would sing those hymns
>> but they would change a couple of the
words
>> and so they would make the the hymn into
a mockery,
>> right?
>> Um and so I kind of wonder if some of
this Christianizing of these occult
rituals is kind of a a mockery to God,
>> right? Um because you know they'll
they'll take a lamb but then it's at
midnight you know and then they've got
like this occult symbolism like where
they're like throwing a child around and
that type thing
>> and like surrounded by candles, right?
>> Yeah. But then
>> Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. But then even we
see it in many churches where the
candles are also again being lit. Like
it's it's like always this mixture of
paganism and a cult and then
Christianity and and he just like draws
people in because why wouldn't you if
you want to deceive the whole world just
like mix a little bit of good with a
little bit of bad,
>> right?
>> Christianity with paganism.
>> The circle is interesting too because
that can also denote sun worship.
>> Yes, that is true. And if you look
actually I think of Target, Walmart, you
know, a lot of the corporations
incorporate that. Um, you guys had on
Little Light Studios a guy named Eric
Wilson, I think was his name, who was in
into uh I'm not sure exactly what form
of martial arts, was really in the
martial arts.
>> He did various ones. He was a disciple
in various arts. Black belt. Yeah.
>> Right. He talks about when it finally
clicked, he was doing some sort of
ceremony or whatever in that martial
arts world that was in a circle. So he
was standing in the middle and his
students were walking in a circle around
him and then he it clicked for him
>> and so he
>> he basically got his students to do
research on it and they all came to the
same conclusion that it's sun worship
and that it was a form of um like like
the ultimate goal of of martial arts was
like to invite the key power which is
possession where you could do like
chopping through ice blocks and the
supernatural the supernatural stuff.
>> Interesting. So it's again to do with
the circle and
>> yeah it's interesting how that all just
those themes are over.
>> But I I just want to ask you a quick
question since you're talking about
Roger Mno. I think Roger Mnau also said
that when I guess he was in a meeting or
heard about a meeting with like Satan
and like some high up individuals
including some religious individuals
where they were um they were discussing
how to deceive the world and that one of
the things they were going to do was
have demons display themselves to people
as their dead loved ones, including
displaying themselves to Christians.
>> But they're really demons. But you just
that's that's spiritualism, right?
That's what many Christians believe that
the soul lives on and therefore you can
see your dead grandpa come visit you. Is
that something that was told to you as
well or that you experienced?
>> I did I would have um I would see people
that I knew to be dead
>> really,
>> you know, that would come to speak to
me, even my father.
Um
but at so at the time I really believe,
you know, I thought that's who it was. I
didn't know
>> it was actually demons. I thought that
that's who I was talking to or
or seeing. And um
it's just a it's just
and my mother always told me, you know,
to be receptive.
>> M
>> if they say something to you, even if
you don't
even if you don't agree with it or even
if you don't know it to be true, if they
say, "Do you agree?" you say yes.
And so um if they come to speak to you,
you talk. if they offer you something,
you take it. That was what she told me.
But it didn't
it didn't sit well with me. Like I could
never get comfortable with it. Um, so
even when my father tried, well, not
really my father, but even when my
father tried to hand me the rain, so to
speak, like take a big um, medallion uh,
chain thing, huge circle with all kinds
of diagrams and writings on it and try
to give it to me
and I would say, "Oh, it's really nice."
I said, you know, give it back because I
just I never
I didn't know anything else, but I
wasn't comfortable
>> with that, per se. I mean,
>> do you look back at that now as kind of
giving permission like
>> Yes, it was. Yeah. I had to give even
though I was covenanted like they agreed
to Satan that I would take up this work.
Um,
I guess I still had to give my consent
in some way,
>> right?
>> Which I didn't know, but I was not
I was kind of delaying as much as I
could because I wasn't really sold
on the idea from just from the stuff
that I saw,
things that I witnessed. And I wasn't
really comfortable. And I think they
kind of knew it, so they needed my
consent because I remember one time I
went to another one of these I keep
saying events cuz I don't know what else
to call it. But um it was like a
gathering and there were a lot of these
people who were into that um occult
thing. It's like the who's who of the
occult and everybody, you know, we all
we all were there. And
I was talking to a friend of mine. He
was my age. I was about 15 maybe. And I
was outside talking to him and we were
standing like shoulderto-shoulder just
talking and laughing. And then while I'm
talking to him, a demon
took possession of him
>> and standing right next to me. And then
it turned to me and it started growling
and it started trying to scratch
my face. And it has such a look of hate.
on his face and I kept, you know, I
couldn't
I couldn't figure it out. I was I was
scared because he was trying to claw me
and he was growling and he looked like
if ever there was a definition of pure
hatred.
That was it.
>> And so I ran and I called someone to
come and get him under under control.
And that night, I kept sitting there and
I kept thinking about it because I'm
like, why does it hate me? We're all on
the same side.
>> And I could not figure out
what did I do? Like I thought we're all
on the same team, but you looked like
you wanted to kill me. And that thought,
I couldn't get that out of my head. But
I feel like now
they maybe knew something that I didn't
know
um about myself. And
>> I don't know. That's the only conclusion
I could come to because at the time I
thought we're all on the same team. Like
I couldn't figure out what was going on.
But um after that you know Satan would
come and he would talk to us and he
would but he would speak softly.
>> How did you know it was Satan?
>> Because we called him prince. We had to
he was the only one we had to address as
sir
>> and we knew him to be the prince of
darkness and we knew and it didn't
click. He's the prince of darkness. What
does that say? It never clicked in my
head or I don't think it clicked in
anyone else's. I don't know that the
prince of darkness kind of means the
devil,
>> right?
>> But um
>> how often would he come and meet with in
these groups?
>> Weekly.
>> And typically on the Sabbath.
>> On the Saturday. Yeah.
>> Wow. M
>> do you feel like some of the hesitation,
you know, and this the feelings that you
had of kind of holding you back looking
back now as a Christian, you think maybe
that was the Holy Spirit?
>> It absolutely was. Yeah. Because
to be honest, I had a lot of I was full
of a lot of anger. Like I could go into
a rage in one second.
And
I felt like like my mother would say
somebody has done something to her and
so she would want to do something back
to them and then they do something to
her. And to me that was foolish. Like if
if you know somebody did something to
you,
>> deal with it one and done. Like why are
you
they cut your hand off so you cut their
hand? No. do like just get rid of them.
So I had that kind of
mentality. I had that kind of
>> I could be very very dark is what I'm
trying to say. So I it was in me,
>> right? You had that nature.
>> Yes. But for some reason
I I still I was hesitant. And even I had
a relationship when I got to be at 18. I
had a boyfriend and he used to say,
"I don't those things are not godly.
They're uh that's demonic." And I used
to say, "You're, you know, he's he don't
know what he's talking about." And he
would say, "Um,
you need to stop practicing this stuff."
And I would say, "That's foolishness."
And
he would say to me now, he didn't tell
me then. He would say there'd be a lot
of times that we were asleep and the
whole bed would start shaking like
violently shaking and it would wake him
up and he would look and it's me that's
violently shaking
>> and and I know I I mean I couldn't wake
up but I knew those times that I was not
in control and I you know I would have a
lot of sleep paralysis too. And then he
would say
um I would look at you sometimes I would
wake up and your body is
in positions that is not possible for a
human being to be in
>> that you would be so contorted in
different shapes and ways and I'm he
never told me this at the time but I'm
thinking now like how in love did you
have to be that you could see another
human being doing these things Mhm.
>> In the middle of the night and you just
go back to sleep and
you know that relationship ended because
he would tell me those things that it's
not of God. And so they they didn't like
that he was opposing it.
And I remember the demons telling me
in a rage one time,
you have to end this relationship.
This is not good. We don't want him. He
is not good for you. Do you agree?
Because I had to consent.
>> Right?
>> And my mother always told me, you say
yes. So he said, he said, do you agree?
And I said, yes, I agree. I didn't
agree, but I was saying yes because I
was told to always say yes. So I said
yes. And not long after that, we the
relationship was just over. that we we
would as soon as he walked in the door,
I can't stand him. As soon as he walked
in the door, he can't stand me. Like, we
just hate when we're apart. I can't wait
for him to get there. He can't wait to
see me. But the minute we got together,
war.
>> Wow.
>> And so that relationship ended. And um I
know now why at the time I didn't I
didn't know why but so after that I
migrated to the US. I was 25
and it started to escalate because they
were tired of waiting for me. I was
taking too long.
>> Who is who is they? Your family or the
demons?
>> The demons and the lady that was waiting
to usher me into it.
>> Okay.
And also my uncle, my mother's brother,
he was kind of waiting because he
thought he used to say, "Your father is
the greatest man that ever lived, that
ever walked this earth because of how
much power he had
and you need to hurry up and
take hold of that power and do the
things that you were meant to do."
And so they I would have visitations at
night
You know, the demons would visit me and
I just
I didn't like it. I was feeling kind of
oppressed.
>> So, would they wake you up or would they
>> Yeah. Yeah. They would wake me up.
>> And would you would you see them or was
it just you would hear them?
>> No, I would see them. They would stand
there and um waiting for me to
>> And what would they say to you? Would
they talk with you or
>> They They were waiting for me to engage
them.
>> Okay. And I I wouldn't
>> because
I didn't want to I didn't I really I
wasn't ready to move forward.
But they came every night and they would
wait. And so after a while I felt like
okay if I don't go to sleep they won't
come maybe.
So I turned on all the TVs, all the
radios, all the stereoss, all the
lights, and I would try to stay awake.
And as soon as I found myself falling
asleep, I would wake myself up cuz my
mother worked at night. So it was just
me in the house. So my godmother back
home,
she became Adventist. And she would tell
me, "This is not godly. This is not of
God. This is demonic." like your mother
is doing demonic things. Your father was
a demon and um and I would think
foolishness. But because she was my
godmother, my mother would send me to
her house
for weekends which included Saturday and
then so she would be keeping the Sabbath
and I would hate it because
I couldn't do anything. I can't watch
TV. I can't I I can't do anything. and
she's just talking about the Bible and
then we just she would just have these
kind of music playing and it would
irritate me.
>> How old were you when she converted to
Adventism and you started visiting her?
>> Um I remember my earliest memory I was
about 13.
>> 13.
>> Do you feel like around that time is
when you started having more of these
hesitations? Maybe she was praying for
you and that was part of the Holy Spirit
kind of
>> I believe she was praying for me because
after I um
at at 25 or 26
when I couldn't take it anymore. I got
on my knees and I said, "Lord, I don't
know who you are, but if you're there,
help me."
This side is saying this is of God. The
other side is saying it's not of God.
Somebody is lying.
I don't know who,
>> right?
>> So, tell me the truth. I mean, and I was
balling because I hadn't slept in weeks
and I'm I'm I'm I'm overwhelmed. I'm
exhausted. I I'm I'm I'm I'm
feeling oppressed. I'm feeling the I'm
feeling the circle tightening around me.
And so I'm balling and I'm talking to a
God I don't know.
I don't know who he is. I don't know if
he's good. I don't know if he's not
good. I don't I don't know. So I'm
saying tell me the truth. Somebody's
lying. And whatever you tell me, that's
what I will do. If you say I have to
take up this work from my father, I will
do it. If you say I don't have to,
I'm happy to not do it. But whatever you
say, that is what I'm going to believe
and that is what I'm going to do. And
looking back on it, I'm thinking, how
can I say that to a god I don't know?
Because what if he told me to do some
crazy stuff and I'm telling him,
whatever you say, I will do it.
>> Right?
And I got up off my knees and it wasn't
until 3 months after that I was laying
in the bed and I heard a voice
saying,
"If you're going to give your life to
the Lord, you have to do it now."
And nobody was there, but I heard the
voice. So, I pulled the blanket over my
head
and I felt the breath, a warm breath
going into my ear saying,
"If you're going to give your life to
the Lord, you must do it now."
Three times it repeated it. You must do
it now.
So, my first thought was, I'm going to
die. I'm going to die and somehow this
God wants to save me. That was my only
thought. And so I knew there was a lady
that lived in my apartment who went to
church and she went on Saturday,
but she was the only church person I
knew. So I called her and I said, "Can I
please go to um your church? I need to
speak to your pastor or whoever's, you
know, priest, pastor, whoever."
And she said, "Sure, let's go today."
And it was a Monday. and we went and he
opened the Bible and I told him
everything from the time I was born up
until that day
and he opened the Bible and he showed me
he said these are demons. It's not
they're not people.
Um the person that you think is
protecting you and is your friend is
actually Satan
and he's not your friend. And everything
that he told me, he showed it to me in
the scriptures.
And I believed him.
And I went home.
And that night, I turned off all the
TVs,
all the radios, all the lights. I went
and I got into bed and I went to sleep.
For the first time in
weeks, I was able to sleep. I slept
because
I believed what he said. I believe the
Bible said that God will protect me.
And I went to sleep. I mean, it was kind
of I don't know if to say it was naive
because you don't leave that life. You
don't get covenanted to Satan and just
decide,
okay, you know, I'm I'm done. And you
just live peacefully. you don't even
live because
I mean they kill you,
>> right?
>> That's what I'm wondering. I'm wondering
if you had said no um and and or you
know not heeded that voice that was
telling you to surrender basically uh if
the demons would have killed you
>> probably because after that night
so my eyes were closed after that I
couldn't see demons anymore
>> really
>> I didn't see demons I didn't see dead
people it just
I could know that you're there But I
couldn't see them
>> anymore. And now if if they attacked me
or they showed up,
it was more like in a dream state.
So it wouldn't be like I'm sitting here
and stuff is going on. It would be more
like in a in a dream and like a spirit
world kind of thing. And then so Satan
now that he knew that I knew who he was
when he came,
he came in his true character. Now he's
no longer speaking softly and wishing me
prosperity and blessings. Now it's like
I'm going to kill you.
That's, you know, that's pretty much
where he said. He like showed me an open
grave and he said, "This is where I want
you to be."
>> Were you having dreams of that or
>> all the time? He would come all the time
and he would
I don't know if to say it's dreams
because it was happening
>> but it would be like if I went to sleep.
>> Gotcha.
>> And did you see his face or just like
the other demons you can't see detail?
>> I wouldn't see his face but if he showed
up a lot of times he would show up in
the image of in the body of the woman.
>> Ha.
the woman that I used to um
go to for
training or whatever if you want to call
it that, he would show up as her a lot
of times, but I knew it was him.
>> Well, that's just an interesting detail
because in the Bible, you know, in
Ephesians, the we we know from that the
the church of God is often referred to
as a woman. You know, looking at the
parallel so far, how he seems to really
be mimicking Christianity in the church.
But then in Revelation, there's a false
woman. You know, we're in jewels, red
and purple, and Babylon. And that's
literally his false church in Bible
prophecy that's been going on for,
>> I don't know, hundreds of years. And is
going to be there in the time to
basically work out the mark of the
beast. It's the Antichrist. It's
synonymous with Babylon. But that's
Satan's church. And so, it's interesting
that here you're saying like, oh, he
came in the form as a woman. It might
not be for everyone. Maybe some other
people see Satan in a male figure, but
in this case, it's just an interesting
detail.
>> You know, these these events where the
all these uh demons would come and
they'd have these kind of rituals and
stuff. You'd have a lot of people there,
like how many people would be there, who
all was there, that type thing.
>> It really depends on
what we were there for.
So if it was just um sometimes people
would come and you could have like 20 pe
you could have 30 people show up because
they all want to have an audience.
>> Okay.
>> With season
>> is this indoors outdoors?
>> Um outdoors.
>> Outdoors. Okay.
>> Yeah. and they all would come and we
would all sit in like a kind of
semicircle kind of thing and
everyone would speak and say,
you know, their stuff. But if you wanted
to say something in private, like if you
wanted to do something to someone, you
wouldn't you would come oneon- one, you
know, you wouldn't want everyone to know
you're about to kill your wife or
something,
you know. Um,
so it all depends. Sometimes we would
have um we would go to the beach to the
seaside
because whatever we did we would
do the rituals and then put it in the
water you know in the ocean and um we
would sometimes do that like Friday
nights into
Saturday
>> Sabbath again.
>> Sabbath again. Yeah. So we would do it
Friday night into when sunset sun up
um Saturday and you could have like 15.
>> So are you like facing the rising sun or
like
>> Yeah, we would sing songs. It was
people felt like they were coming to
church, but I mean
>> you would have a lot of drumming. you
would have a lot of singing and clapping
and
sometimes depending on the demon um like
a lot of it was kind of like a African
kind of
you know like setting so like the
drumming and the some kind of African
dancing type thing sometimes.
Um, and different demons a lot of times,
you know, have different names and they
would say they're from a different part
of the world
sometimes.
>> Do you remember any of the names or
locations or anything?
>> Some of them would say that they um
they're originally from they're in a
that they left Africa to come over to
where we are or somebody would come from
India.
not somebody, you know, a demon from
India or some someone another one
>> um China Chinese
um that Yeah. So it wasn't specific to
to where we were.
And um
so right after that I left and I went
came back to my country
and my godmother told me
I I have somebody that I want you to
meet. His name is Pastor Harris. And I
said sure fine. you know, um, what
happened was she was praying while all
of this was going on. I didn't know
while I was in the US, she was praying
and she had a a person that would come
and they would pray on a specific day at
a specific time. They would pray and
fast for me.
And so when she heard that I was coming
back to visit,
they asked the Lord to um to send
someone
who could deliver me.
And so they prayed and fasted and then
they decided Claude was the guy that
would pray with her. Claude would go to
the conf the local conference and find a
pastor there that could talk to me
along those lines of my background. And
so Claude went on this particular day
and his prayer was, you know, I want the
first person, the first pastor that I
meet to be the one that you want to
speak to her.
And so he said as he opened the door to
walk into the conference, Pastor Harris
was coming out. But Pastor Harris was a
retired pastor and he just went there
that day to visit some other pastor. And
as he was coming out, Claude was coming
in. And so Claude took that as a sign
that this was the man God sent.
And so he told him my story and he said,
"Yes, let her come to my house cuz he
was retired."
So I went to his house
and turns out that was his specialty.
That was what he did. Like he
um delivered people from demonic
possession. And I didn't know I was
possessed. Um, but that's what he did.
But I never forgot. One of the things he
told me
was that there was a woman that was
possessed in front of him, like sitting
across from him, and he was there to to
deliver her.
And while he was talking to her, he
said, "Satan himself
took possession of the woman and said to
Pastor Harris, this particular person is
very important to me."
So I didn't want to trust this to any
anyone under me. I came here, I left my
seat in Rome
>> to come and deal with this myself.
>> Wow. Really? So he's normally in Rome
>> in the Vatican.
>> Wow.
>> I mean at this time I was I wasn't
baptized. I didn't know any of that type
of anything but I remember I left my
seat in Rome.
>> Yeah. Well maybe just a very brief
context for people to understand why
this is so important. Um so not just us
as many of the reformers who've gone
through the dark ages and the
reformation you know the original
reformers there's lists and lists of
people who appointed as the papacy in a
Vaticanist the antichrist and we say
this with all due respect to Catholics
>> not an attack on Catholics but we
believe this according to Bible prophecy
and that's why this is significant
>> right yeah
>> yeah and so um Pastor Harris ended up um
I would go once a week
and he would tell me, you know, more
about my situation and what I really
was, you know, doing. And and then he
asked me, did I want to get baptized?
And and I did because I I wanted to be I
wanted to be free.
So he baptized me back home and um
because his eyes were open to these
things. He said that once I went down
into the water,
12 uh demons left me.
>> He could he could see them um coming
out. And um
I have to say
once that happened, once I came into the
to the Adventist faith, the Lord showed
me a vision
of what I was going through um when I
was in Brooklyn. And he showed me again
a circle
and I was in the middle of the circle.
And so my mother, that woman, and all
the other people,
and the circle was getting smaller and
smaller, and I was in the middle, and I
wanted to get out, but I did not know
how to get I there was no way for me to
get out and and my, you know, my heart
was racing. I was so scared because
it's them, but they all have these
demonic looks and and and you know their
their faces and they were they were so
evil looking and they were closing in on
me. And right when they put their hand
out to grab me,
a big hand came from in the clouds
and came down and snatched me out of the
circle right as they were about to grab
me.
And years later, um, reading the Bible,
I came across Psalm 18
verse 16 where it says, "He sent from
above. He took me and drew me out of
many waters. That was a how I felt was
was that moment God came and snatched me
out
>> right on time. And I feel like if he
didn't snatch me out and they had got a
hold of me,
my life may have been very very
different.
I may have
fully consented and fully opened myself
up to Satan to be used
like my father was. Um
that's why the Lord had to snatch me out
right on time.
And every time I think about that, I
feel like
I feel like I'm not
I'm not doing enough to show how
grateful I am. Like that was a huge
deliverance for me. Like, and to think
that I was serving Satan. I didn't know
I didn't know who God was. I didn't know
him. I didn't I wasn't doing anything to
please him.
But he
he knew me and he had his eyes on me.
And right when I needed help the most,
he snatched me.
And
you know that to me is is hope for
anybody that is living that same life,
walking that same path. And sometimes
you feel like maybe
you're too much in it or you're too far
in it or
it's not as long as you want to be free.
>> Amen.
>> God God He's waiting. He's waiting for
you to just have a thought of that
freedom
and he will answer.
And
so even though I got baptized and even
though I became Adventist, I still
wasn't I still wasn't 100%
free. I would still have attacks. I
would still be harassed all the time. I
would still because Satan doesn't just
give up. He doesn't just say, "Oh, she's
gone." You know, in his mind, you were
mine. Your father gave me consent. Your
mother gave me consent. You belong to
me, and I'm not giving up.
And it wasn't until
I was watching amaz uh one of those
sites and I saw the dragon revealed Eric
Wilson.
>> Mhm.
>> Wow.
>> And I saw him talking and I thought he
was talking about warfare and that type
of thing and I thought I'm going to give
him a call. So, I looked up Isaiah
Ministries and I called him. I emailed
him and he called me back and I told him
what was going on and he sent me um
scriptures from the Bible. He said,
"You're free. You just don't know you're
free. You have to believe you're free."
And he sent me all these promises um and
scriptures from the Bible and he said,
"Say them out loud every day." And I
started doing that. And it's not because
it was magic in the thing. It's because
the more I said it out loud, the more I
believed it.
>> M.
>> So it took me getting baptized in 1997.
And it wasn't until I met him in 2015
that I was finally finally free.
>> Amen. And then my uncle, that uncle who
you know was waiting for me to um
be the greatest woman that ever lived
like my father who was the greatest man
that ever lived. That same uncle um he
was having a lot of problems and I he
lived in Boston. He still is. And I told
him, you know, you have to give up that
lifestyle.
And he said, "I don't know how because
I'm afraid. I'm afraid if I walk away,
they will kill me."
And which he had every right to be
afraid.
And so I I I went to Boston
from Tennessee. I drove and I went to
his house and he had an altar and he had
all these things that my mother had and
um he was very scared. I said, "You have
to get rid of all this stuff." And he
was like um he was very he's like you
sure? I said yes. You know the Lord is
going to help me.
I'm not doing this on my own. The Lord
is with me and he is going to give me
the the authority to do it. And so I
got rid of everything, you know, broke
everything, scrubbed the walls clean,
did all this stuff. And he's standing
there petrified because he's waiting to
see me drop dead.
And I said to the Lord, you know, this
is a time for you to show who's in
charge, who is the real boss, who is the
king of kings, and who is in subject to
who. He has to see it for himself so he
could believe it.
And so just based on that mindset,
knowing that the Lord was going to use
this opportunity to glorify himself and
show his power and to show that if
you're on his side, you're okay. I knew
I would be okay just because of that.
And um I got rid of all of the stuff. I
told him, you know, let's pray. And I
prayed a deliverance prayer for him. And
I gave him um scripture and the same
things Eric gave me I gave him.
And um to this day he he he has never
gone back because after I left and I
went to my hotel he called me and he
kept calling me calling me. He was like
I'm just calling to see that you're
still alive. I said I am and I will be.
God is protecting me. You know, the same
way the devil has demons, God has strong
angels. You know, the Bible says he's a
Lord of hosts and he has given me some
of those from his host to protect me.
And it's the same thing he will do for
you if you just trust him and you just
believe him. And I think the more the
longer I stayed alive, the more um the
more he believed it. And so that was in
2022. I was able to do that for him.
>> Amen.
>> Awesome. Amen.
>> Yeah.
>> So, so Lauren, um you mentioned earlier,
I'm I'm just curious about this. You
mentioned earlier that people uh would
go to the beach on a Friday evening and
have like these ceremonies and stuff.
>> Why do people want to get involved with
this? Because you got to the other side
of it in Christianity and it's so much
better. Why do are people attracted to
these kind of things?
One of the things I feel like is
something you can have control over.
Like you can say what you want to happen
for your life. Like I want this husband.
I want you know like the way my mother
was trapped
by my father and she couldn't leave even
though she didn't want him.
um you have some kind of power.
And
even now I say sometimes to the Lord, I
understand why people go to psychics and
and seers and witchcraft people because
I you want an answer right now. You
know, you can pray to the Lord and say,
"Lord, such and such and such and I have
things I've been praying for. I have a
son I've been praying for eternally. And
I'm like, I see why people go because
they can go and get what they think is
immediate results,
>> but they don't know that
you're you're you're opening yourself up
now to demons. And if you stay that way,
you're you're essentially lost.
Um, but I think it's a power thing,
>> right? Like sometimes my father used to
pay if he had to pay somebody money,
you come to his house and he count the
money out and he put it in an envelope
and he give it to you and you go home
and when you open it, it's leaves from a
tree.
>> It's not money and you cannot go back
and tell him you didn't pay me. If you
want to live,
you accept those leads, you know. So my
uncle loved that. He used to talk about
that. He used to say that is such power.
I want that power
and and so a lot of people
I think that's what attracts them to it
and the um the immediate help because
and then you could live any life you
want. You could do whatever you want.
You could have
three wives like my mother was not the
only one in the house. It's like
>> we had other wives
>> there. I mean, you could just live
>> however you want. You were not bound by
any by any rules of of anything.
>> Yeah.
>> And you can just and have whatever you
want. And it's an illusion, too, because
some people are in sub abject poverty,
but they kept coming.
>> Kept coming. They're giving their last
dollar for you to help them and they're
still in the same state, but they would
keep coming.
>> I don't understand. It's like a
brainwashing.
>> Yeah. And but Jesus wants to give us the
opposite of that, you know. Yeah.
>> So, it's it's I think it's just amazing
>> that you came to the other side of that
and was a able to be set free like that.
Um, I'm just thinking of a conversation
Alex and I had yesterday where he talked
me a little bit about your testimony. He
mentioned something about maybe like
high up people in society getting
involved with this and these meetings or
like the Super Bowl. Can you tell us a
little bit about that?
>> Yeah. So, it's like um politicians came,
you know, when they wanted stuff to go
in their favor or
you had somebody that was opposing you
in some way and you the only way to
to win is if they died or something. Um
so people came
to do the people politicians would come
and and sometimes they would want
protection because politicians were
always doing witchcraft and voodoo stuff
or cult stuff to each other.
>> Wow.
>> Like like politicians from from the
Caribbean or like western as well
everywhere. Like like US politicians and
>> anybody.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. because because he because my my
dad like I said a lot of people who did
oult and did voodoo um they would say
okay you have to
go buy this animal and bring it back and
we'll do such and such and such. He
didn't do any of that because he worked
directly with with demons face to face.
that he when he was 17, he went into the
forest and he was there
for like I want to say 30 days
30 40 days something like that. He was
there where the demons were face to face
talking to him and training him and and
when he came back out of the forest is
when he began this work. So he was kind
of a notch above
the others which is why people came to
him. So you can come to him and you can
say I I want a new wife. This is who she
is and I don't want this wife anymore.
And he would say okay fine just go home
and you can go home and when you go home
the wife is dead
>> already.
You know it's so
>> so your father must have been he must
have been fairly wealthy then.
I
I wouldn't say he was wealthy, but he
didn't lack anything,
>> right? Anything he wanted basically he
could have if he wanted it,
>> right? because I found my mother had a
receipt for um jewelry that they bought
me as a baby.
And I looked at the receipt. The cost of
it
to buy that in 1971
was very expensive and for a baby.
>> Yeah.
>> But um Yeah. So people came and then if
you were into sports and you had you
know big big things coming up where you
can win a tournament, you win a you win
money, you win a league,
you would come to him and he would say
okay. And then you know you would win
every game you win every and then you
move up and then finals and everything
and then you're the winner
>> like the Super Bowl, right? like you
mentioned.
>> Yeah.
>> So, can you tell me a little bit about I
mean it sounds like he he would have
been very well known outside of the
Caribbean even. I mean he's known in
multiple countries then. Fairly fairly
well known in certain circles then
>> because he used to have to come to
America as well.
>> What would he come to America for?
>> To do stuff for people that you know
someone needed something done
>> and they wanted him personally
>> um to come. And then some things you
wouldn't back then I there weren't
telephones.
>> Yeah.
>> So yeah. So it's not like you could call
him up and say such and such. You would
have to send him a message, send him a
letter, send him somehow. And these
people would buy him plane tickets and
pay for him to, you know, to stay
wherever so that he could stay with them
for a while and they can get whatever
they need done. Did you did you ever
like because obviously he was you know
arranging these well you Satan was
arranging these competition these games
>> um you know for the people who made the
sacrifices. Do you remember a particular
Super Bowl or competition where your dad
was like okay now these are going to win
and you saw them win every single game
>> I was cuz I was so little.
>> Right. Right. Yeah. So I I don't have I
I can't remember stuff like that.
>> But um
that was my life. I mean even um I went
to church in Brooklyn and my stepfather
came with me. They were having a crusade
and he came every night and then at the
end of it they asked does anybody want
to be baptized? and he stood up and I
was so shocked and my mother was very
very angry because she's still in that
life and she was very angry and he got
baptized and he was so happy and then he
was looking for a job and he wouldn't
take one on the Sabbath
>> and she was very very angry and she
would say if you don't take one on the
Sabbath
and if that's the only job you can get
if you don't take it you have to leave.
And he did that for weeks and weeks and
he couldn't find one. And finally he
took a job and um where he had to work
on the Sabbath.
>> And one Sabbath he went to work and he
was driving this huge truck that had
like
one, two, like like eight or six sets of
wheels. I don't know how much but these
very big heavy trucks and he was driving
the truck and he parked the truck and
the as he was jumping out the truck
started to roll and he fell out of the
truck but he how that happened I don't
know but he fell and he ended up under
the truck
>> and the truck rolled
and crushed him crushed his chest and
everything.
And that was on Sabbath. And um
he died at the hospital.
And that really bothered me, you know. I
was like, Lord, I just really want to
know was he saved? I know he went to
work on the Sabbath, but she was
torturing him.
And I said, you know, was he saved or
was he lost? And 3 months after that, a
man called from his job and he said,
"You know, I'm so sorry it took me so
long to call, but I'm curious because
when we pulled him from under the truck,
his hands were folded and he was
praying." M
>> and I felt so relieved because I felt
like the Lord was saying
um he for and the explanation was
I forgave him
but still had to put him to sleep
because if I healed him he was coming
back to that house to live with her
>> right
>> and so he could not it was better to
save him and let him die than to send
him back to live in a house where Satan
is welcome.
>> Mhm.
>> Right.
>> He wasn't strong enough to fight her.
>> So, do you see a lot of people kind of
like from your community or even people
who have seen coming to your dad?
Doesn't matter if it's, you know, these
well well-known famous people or or
regular people. Have you seen them
coming to Christ or is it very difficult
to leave?
>> I would say it's difficult to leave. I
think that because I did not consent and
I never
um
it's not something I wanted to do.
So I think the Lord was able to
people have to have to be people have to
want to be free. They have to want
to know the truth. They have to they
have to want it. You know the Lord
doesn't force you. Yeah.
>> Um, he will present it to you and and
you choose. I didn't have the
opportunity for it to be presented to me
except hearing my godmother now and then
say, you know, this is not the truth.
Um, and I think the reason I didn't
accept it as a child is because I would
not have survived accepting it as a
child under my mother. So even though I
was hearing it then, I couldn't accept
it then. I had to accept it as an adult
because even after I accepted it, my
mother always said it's foolishness. The
church cannot help you. If something
were to happen to you, they cannot help
you.
>> I mean, you who you know who your father
is. Why would you walk away? This is who
you're meant to be. And I would say,
"No, I am delivered from that." And she
would say, "We'll see.
We we're just giving you a little space,
but when we're ready for you,
>> you will have no choice. She used to say
that to me, but that was how many years
ago? I've I'm free.
>> Amen.
>> You know, I'm not going back to that
life.
>> You found out who your father really
was.
>> Exactly.
>> Exactly. Because when I came to church,
I I would pray and I would say, "Lord, I
had all the characteristics of my
earthly father.
I was a very angry person and I used to
have very wicked thoughts.
I could do very wicked things easily.
So now I want you to be now that you are
my father, I want you to give me your
characteristics.
I want to have the thoughts that you
have
and the mindset that you have.
>> Amen.
>> Opposite to what I had before.
And those are the kinds of things the
Lord wants to hear, you know, because
that's what he wants to do for all of
us,
>> right? He knocks at the door. He's just
waiting for us to let him in.
>> Absolutely. Now, you mentioned
throughout your your upbringing that um
you mentioned that you were going to a
Catholic was it a Catholic school or a
Catholic church?
>> Catholic school. Yeah.
>> Did you go to uh like a Catholic church
on uh Sunday like typical church? So,
how long did that did that go on for?
Did you go through all the typical mass
and everything else and etc?
>> I Yes, I did. And I went I um did first
communion
at whatever age you do that. Um
because
I didn't go like I just went when
because it was a Catholic school. They
took us all the time and we would have
to do uh confession and all this
stuff and go to church and say mass and
and you know and do all of that. I think
once I
once I became a teenager,
maybe 6:15
around that time, I just stopped going.
It just it was boring to me. Like I just
go and sit there
>> and the priest say something and you say
something and
that was it. That it that was it was
just boring.
>> So I just stopped go I just stopped
going.
M
>> yeah.
>> Did you get a sense cuz obviously I mean
at least later on with your family, you
know, you kind of discovered about
Seventh Day Adventists, but did you get
a sense in those people in the voodoo or
the occult world, did they look at uh
Catholics different than they would
Sabbathke keepers like Seventh Day
Adventist or was there any any sense of
that at all?
>> It's cool if you if you if you're a
Catholic.
>> It's cool if you're Catholic.
>> Yeah, you can do both.
>> Okay.
>> It's
>> So the demons were okay with that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Because my mother was also
Anglican.
>> Okay.
>> Which is the same. Yeah. Right.
>> So she was a part of both.
>> But if you became 7th day Adventist,
that's a whole different
ball game. Like you're the enemy.
>> Right. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Now was your did your father have a
specific religion? Was he Catholic as
well or don't know?
>> No, he just did what he did.
>> Okay. Gotcha.
>> That was it. But you know, he knew what
he was doing,
>> right?
>> Because my my godmother was already
Adventist when she became my godmother.
>> And he said,
and lots of people wanted to be my
godmother and my godfather because of
who my father was. They just wanted to
be close to him.
and he said, "I'm going to choose her to
be my godmother because
she will be able to show me both sides
of the coin."
>> Now, in my mind,
you're worshiping Satan like Satan is
your master.
Everything you do is what he tells you
to do. He's in your house regularly.
You speak to him face to face. Why would
you want somebody
to tell me the other side? So to me,
that was the Lord doing that because
there's no way there's no way I want
somebody to even whisper to you that
this is this this is wrong or this is
demonic.
So the fact that he chose her and said
those words, I don't even feel like he
had control over that because it was her
telling me and it was her prayers that
led me to Pastor Harris
who ultimately um baptized me and told
me all the things that he told me. It
was her. So why would you choose her
knowing that that was a possibility and
knowing that you had me set to do your
work? Doesn't make sense.
>> I wonder.
>> Yeah, I think that certainly could be.
I'm just wondering and this could be
could be totally wrong if maybe it's
also for you to do his work and to have
that special power if you had to have an
understanding of the truth to be able to
fully reject it.
>> That's a good point. I never thought of
that. Yeah, obviously the Holy Spirit
worked through that, but I wonder if
that was maybe part of it as well.
>> Yeah, I think it's possibly great
because he knew what he was doing,
>> right?
>> He knew fully what side he was on,
>> right? And to fully consent, you have to
have all the information.
>> Yeah, you're absolutely right.
>> So, is there any kind of specific uh uh
leadup to some of these big events that
are, you know, basically dedicated to
Satan? Was there any discussion about
that
>> like the Super Bowl and stuff,
>> right?
>> Mhm.
>> So, you would know like who's going to
win beforehand because it's it's going
to be because it's going to be um the
demons that control the game.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. So, you know, you already know
who's going to win. Like if you know how
you have all these big um athletes,
super athletes,
>> god they're just so um Yes, people are
talented.
>> Mhm. But
a lot of them, it's not them
>> that's doing it and it's not them that's
winning it.
Um, it's all
it's all um predetermined.
And a lot of them who are the big super
athletes and so on, they know that it's
not them.
>> So, you're saying a lot of these
athletes know it's not them. Um, you
know, me coming from Little Light
Studios, we talk a lot about
celebrities, specifically in the music
industry, in the movie industry, actors
that, yeah, they give hints, sometimes
they openly say it that they worship the
the prince of this world. I believe it's
even uh Bob Dylan who even said like
>> crossroads deal.
>> Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
>> Why do you still do it? Why are you
still out here? Well, it goes back to
the destiny thing. I mean, I made a
bargain with it, you know, long time
ago, and I'm holding up my hand.
>> What was your bargain?
>> To get where um I am now.
>> Should I ask who you made the bargain
with
>> with with with with, you know, with the
chief uh chief commander
>> on this earth?
>> On this earth and in a world we can't
see. But I've never really heard it say
about athletes. So, but but are you
saying that since a lot of them know
it's not them doing it, are they some of
them dabbling with these kind of things?
Like they're dabbling with the
>> Yeah, they they have to be some of them
to be at the level that they are,
>> right? They have to be.
>> Are you familiar with Tom Brady's former
wife Jazelle and that whole
>> Oh, are they divorced?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, they've been divorced
for a couple years now, but when he
first went to Tampa Bay, um he he's like
getting his hair done. He's telling the
story to these reporters, and he's
basically saying that his wife is a
witch, but she's a good witch.
>> And she she essentially told him that he
would have to do this, this, and this in
order to win the Super Bowl. It was
going to take a lot of work, but you it
sounds like you're familiar with that as
well.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I heard it and I thought,
"Yep, sounds right."
>> Well, it's interesting.
that. Um, oh, what is what is Taylor
Swift's boyfriend name? Travis. Travis
Kelce. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I mean, we've done a video on our
channel about Taylor Swift and kind of
went deep into it and she's hugely
involved in the occult and and like um
magic and witchcraft and and and all
these kind of things. And so, yeah, you
would assume if you're as an athlete
dating someone like that, you must know
something. You must know, right? And you
know their team, I'm not making uh
making statements here that you know
about why their team won. I don't know
what what transpired behind the scenes
about that, but their team did win.
>> They did. Yeah.
>> Yep. First year they were dating,
>> right?
>> Well, it's it it kind of hearkens to
what you're saying though because there
was Tom Brady when he's having that
interview with I think it was like a
Gillette commercial or something like
that where he's talking to the barber or
something like that for for it. Um, and
he said that uh his his wife Jazelle had
to repeat the you know had to have him
repeat these mantras and things like
that. And so it's this kind of
ritualistic ceremony type thing that she
was having him do.
>> I think he had like a altar in his
locker as well if I remember correctly.
>> I I'd have to go back and watch it. Um
it it kind of reminds me exactly of what
you're saying though um about you know
how the devil works to try and kind of
influence things like this um to get
people on his side. Yeah.
>> So, um the other question I had is um we
know that Satan has a lot of plans for
the future that there is going to be a
big deception that is coming um you know
here at the end of time um and that he
has but a few short years left or or you
know a short amount of time I should say
left to work. Um, did you have any kind
of discussion about plans for the
future? Cuz Roger Morno talked in his
books about how there would be a you
know grand meeting every hundred years
and that that's also discussed by um
>> Alice Alice Bailey actually she mentions
that as well.
>> Um and Alice Bailey actually said the
last meeting was in 1925 and the next
one would be in 2025. And um so I'm
curious, did you or your father or any
anybody that you know that was connected
with the occult like this ever discuss
the future, the plans that Satan had for
humanity kind of going forward to try
and make them believe a lie?
>> I think that if I had
if I was living that life, if I had um
consented and I had gone into it
>> Mhm.
um I would have gotten that kind of
information that kind of Yeah.
>> I you know I could have been in that
kind of discussion
>> right
>> but I think that well at the time that I
left
>> Mhm.
>> I hadn't had anything like that before.
And one other thing I have to say
because I was as possessed as I was
without knowing it. I mean no one knew
it. I seemed normal.
But um there a lot of times people would
say to me now do you remember such and
such and such
>> or do you remember when you said such? I
have no recollection because it was not
me having the conversation.
>> It it it wasn't I wasn't present.
>> So
>> it was my body was present. I was
talking to you but it wasn't me. So that
time when you had your friend that was
sitting next to you, you said you had a
friend that was standing next to you
shouldertosh shoulder and they suddenly
became possessed and turned to you. Do
you think that you had moments like that
when the when demons took over and you
were not in control?
>> Yes.
>> But you don't remember you don't
remember any of that or were you ever
told after the fact that that happened?
>> Not an episode like him.
>> Okay.
>> Just um stuff that was out of the norm
for me. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Interesting.
>> Yeah. And then but I don't remember it
because
I wasn't present.
>> Right.
>> I wanted to highlight something that you
said because I think it's so important,
you know, when you called Eric and he
basically, you know, told you to recite
these Bible verses and believe the
promises, believe the blessings. Um,
have you read uh Roger Morno's book,
Beware of Angels?
>> Yeah. There's a there's a part in that
book uh and just for the audience who
may not have uh basically just kind of
briefly the premise is there's this this
group of actual Christians who want to
meet with angels and so they start
praying to meet with an angel and an
angel does come and kind of slowly you
know gains their trust and then
ultimately gets them to do horrific
things including uh murdering people
eventually.
>> Yeah. Um, but they repented and turned
away and after they were arrested and
were in jail and they were uh writing
letters back and forth with Roger
because they were still being tormented
and they couldn't understand why they
were being tormented.
>> And it uh turns out that they were
praying and asking for forgiveness, but
they were doing it over and over and
over because deep down they didn't
believe that they could be forgiven for
what they had done.
>> And that when you said that, it reminded
me of that as well. I mean it's that
that faith that belief it's so important
so powerful.
>> Yeah. Because it's I
I think because of the relationship I
had with my mother as well. Um she hated
my father essentially. I mean she
carried on and and what he was doing.
But she hated him for ruining her life
as she calls it. you know, taking her as
a young girl and being having to be with
him and and show you to say an old guy
that I would never want. And um
she blamed him for ruining her life. And
then she had me because of that.
And
so growing up, I think once I started to
be a teenager, she would say things
like, "You're just like your father." M
>> and so she essentially took out
her feelings. She did she couldn't do it
to him, so she did it to me. You know,
it was it was displaced essentially. And
so once I became Adventist,
I couldn't see God past
how I saw her,
>> you know, how I could never be good
enough for her. I could never do
anything right for her,
>> right?
>> I no matter what I achieved, it
>> it didn't it it didn't do anything.
Someone could do less and it would be
great. And I achieve I was an A student
all through school
and it was always Yeah. M. So when I
came into the church and I was trying to
know who God is, I always saw myself
behind everyone else.
>> I would see God having his children. I
love you all so much and I am behind
here looking at that because
I I'm not good, you know. I'm not I'm
not included. I'm not
I'm just always just good enough for
being, you know, in the back and
watching everyone be blessed and
watching everyone
be loved. And I um I couldn't
I had that for many many years like I
think up until Eric that is how I felt
that God saw me
because he was my parent now and the
only parent I had saw me that way. So,
>> you know, reading that um you know,
beware of angels and then hearing it
again kind of reaffirmed for you because
I have those same thoughts as well that
I'm not good enough. And I and I had
caught myself. The reason that quote
really stuck to me is there were things
in my life that I felt God may not be
able to forgive me for.
>> And I had asked for that over and over.
And so that was so powerful reading that
it's like, okay, I I can trust his
promises. I can believe in that.
>> So, we all we all need that. Mhm.
>> Yes, we do.
>> Yep.
>> My mother now, she's out of her mind.
She's
>> She's has dementia.
>> She's not coherent.
I still pray for her. I don't know.
I don't know. But
I mean, it's nothing you can talk to her
about because
she she understands nothing.
>> And I know 95%
of it is demonic.
I know that she's in that state. It's
demonic.
Um, so I just continue praying for her.
I don't know if she will ever consent in
her head, in her mind if she
wants to be free because she still
believes the devil is taking care of
her.
>> She still thinks that he protects her
>> and
it's very sad to me.
Um, but I can't I can't force her
>> Mhm.
>> to think otherwise. I
I just asked the Lord to go and have an
encounter with her. You know, if you go
and have an encounter with her, all the
demons have to sit back and let you talk
to her and then, you know, present it to
her and let her choose. That's what I
pray all the time for her.
Do you still have a lot of family and uh
um acquaintances and friends or not
friends but you know people that you
knew that are still deeply involved with
all of this even to this day? Do you
ever hear anything from them or talk
with any of them or see them or
anything?
>> Yeah. And I tried to tell them that you
know it's not this. It really isn't. And
um
I don't know I don't know what is the
difference between when I was in it and
they're in it. Why they're not even I
say okay so you talk to the prince of
darkness.
The Bible says Jesus is the prince of
light. He's the prince of peace. So who
do you think the prince of darkness is?
>> Yeah. And
it's like one person said, "Well, I
don't care.
I don't care because he does good things
and he does bad things. So, he does
both, so I don't care."
>> So, did you ever speak to Satan
yourself? And and what was it like
hearing him? You said, I believe
earlier, that uh he he spoke very
softly. Uh what what
>> he spoke very softly. He spoke. He would
always um wish you peace and wish you
prosperity. He spoke very
like you would think he's kind because I
thought he was my friend. I thought he
was the one that was protecting me.
>> I thought he was my helper.
If I have a problem, I figure well, you
know, he could handle it.
um not knowing that the problems are
coming because he's doing it.
Um that's how he spoke.
Um he was very happy one day when I said
um he was telling me that somebody
said something about me
and I I was so angry to hear that they
said that and I said, you know, they
need to be careful because I have no
problem
giving permission for their car
to turn over with them in it. And he was
so happy. He started laughing. He was
like, "You would kill them." And I was
like, "Yes."
>> Wow.
>> And that made him so happy
>> to know that that's something I would I
would do.
>> He sounds like a psychopath.
>> I know he is.
>> Literally. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Wow.
>> Wow. Well, you know, it's a it's a
really amazing testimony that you have
that God, like you said, you know, that
hand could pluck you out of the middle
of darkness. Uh that's
>> that's absolutely amazing. Um
>> it is
>> right on time,
>> right?
>> Yeah. The more stories I hear like this,
like you, Roger Morno, other people, the
more encouraging it is like like
>> he calls himself the prince of this
world, but ever since Jesus died on the
cross, he's won the world and all of our
hearts back for him. And
>> all we have to sue is do is say yes like
you did, you know, and and he reigns. He
Jesus
>> truly is king of kings, lord of lords,
and he's coming back soon,
>> right?
>> Yes.
>> Amen.
>> Praise the Lord. Well, um, thank you
very much for, uh, giving your
testimony. I know I know it's, uh,
probably not easy to talk about a lot of
this because you've lived it and it's,
uh, it's been a real challenge, but, uh,
praise God that he's able to rescue us
from the depths of depravity, from the
depths of sin, all of us. Um, and that
he wants something so much better for us
as a result of it.
>> So,
>> yeah.
>> Yes. I thank God. And I hope this
testimony can
can help somebody if they think, you
know, they're too far gone or they're
too or they're afraid. Cuz a lot of
people don't leave it because they're
afraid because he makes them afraid that
if you leave, this is what will happen
to you. But I just want people to know
that he is subject to Christ.
>> Yeah.
>> And if you hold if you hold out your
hand to Christ, he is waiting to hold
his hand out to you. And once you're in
his hand, no one can take you out of it.
No one and nothing can take you out of
it. You yourself have to say, "I want to
come out of it." Other than that, he is
holding on tight. And Satan has to ask
permission to him
to do anything to you. He He doesn't He
does not have that power to do anything
that Christ does not give him the power
to do or the permission to do. So if you
want to leave, you can leave. If you
want to be free, you can be free. And
you're never too far gone, no matter
what it is that you think you've done.
>> Yeah. I just want to emphasize as the
summary like basically of what you're
saying is that when I hear this I think
if Satan sorry if God saved you
literally from Satan's hands surely he
can do anything to help us
>> in in any of our struggles, trials,
temptations, addictions, anything is
nothing's too hard for God as the Bible
says.
>> Nothing is too hard for God.
>> Well, that's a perfect summary.
Well, thank you for sharing your
testimony. I think you're going to bless
many people through this video. I know
I've personally been blessed.
>> Thank you for
what it's about.
>> If you like this video, like, subscribe,
>> and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos
>> and drop a comment below and we'll try
to get back to you if we can.
>> What?
>> Say that again. No.
>> No. I don't know what to say.
[Music]